[Applause]
brie Larson surprises moviegoers at a
showing of Captain Marvel in eight
Captain Marvel tracksuit so thank you so
much for coming you guys are so awesome
to come like opening weekend Bri was
also snapped working concessions serving
up popcorn and soda for fans how did I
get here what is happening to me and it
is moments like that that I think about
it's also like all of the auditions that
I was rejected at but I think about you
know because I think on these press
tours it's an exciting time it's the
time that we're talking about like
positive things and you see a movie
that's a finished product that has all
of my best takes in it but we don't talk
about all of the times that I hit the
floor and then get back up again higher
further faster famous Captain Marvel
sword with a hundred fifty three million
dollar domestic opening weekend et spoke
with Larson about being the first woman
to helm her own Marvel film I've just
always had that thing inside of me where
I just I'm not gonna give up I'm not
gonna roll over and so it feels really
good to stand here today and to go
really honestly all of that stuff every
time I hit the floor and we can say that
that is with auditions roles I didn't
get dudes that didn't like me and I can
also say that about the physical
training of this movie of like doing
wirework stunts where I missed my feet
slipped and fell and hit the ground but
all that stuff ended up in this movie
and there's a huge part of what this
film really is so I feel like it
embodies with it what it says it is
you
[Music]